Fahim Anwar is the second Afghan
American we've had on this podcast I
want to thank you all really who's the
first Tony Kazim Oh like he does MMA
stuff right like yeah doesn't he train
Marshawn Lynch - yes he does
be smoked baby yeah he's be so Doug oh
yeah cuz you're a Seahawks fan yeah yeah
you see Tariq I've never met him I've
only heard a Pashtun elder you you bat
out yeah he's in the bay he's yes okay
maybe I'll just text me I should train
with him for no reason get ready for
just post corona world know what I'm
doing stand always that character and
say I want to work on my high kicks
that's all I want to work on just tires
and high kicks he's all kisses really
not my thing I'm just trying to hide
cake man I just want to do a high kicks
yeah what was that character he's Lance
Lance can't stop Louis when it's been a
wellness dude like I didn't do him for
two years like I just took that time off
did you ever see him do it no oh my god
heard about it done he's my wife beater
right or tank yeah yeah yeah mohamad
small this prithi Oh
like Lance predates thios mom he's the
first post 80s first mullet at the
Comedy Store
Oh 100% yeah I did a documentary called
Lance can't stop was out of nowhere it's
on YouTube so really it's like a 14
minute doc on Lance and some of the
Comedy Store [ __ ] do your videos make me
laugh so hard
thanks man dude it's incredible how good
of a [ __ ] dancer you are you know
that's kind of a weird thing that it's
this or go back you know it's the second
one do ya know verify here this is the
intro yeah here it is play this
[Music]
the info is really cool everybody come
into this world a blank slate but you
know that's led up to you
I made sure mine was [ __ ]
you're here really like that no they
were just it's a weave so like whenever
glance is about to go up I would like
duck out into the back bar the Comedy
Store and I would like clip these weaves
into the back and then I would have the
wife beater underneath my clothes I'm
like Superman changing before going on
stage and then they would announce me
and then Lance would just dance for like
a minute up top and just do QA this is
so fun but yeah Bobby's in the stock
Neal Brennan zanuck kumail's in it Mary
Lynn Rajskub
Jeff Ross so like you know don't like
we're cool enough to be in it I sought
the other day I'm like aw man I just I
missed this place you know God knows
[ __ ]
yeah so that's the intro but so I didn't
do them for two years people were like
oh where did you go how come you don't
do it anymore
let's do a look so I actually did it one
time before this virus like came I
brought him back and then this hit you
did at the store yeah before everything
shut down and it was so fun dude yeah I
can't play it yeah you can't try to find
a standard clip like the one before it
or actually go to L can't stop us on
Instagram uses known as the in zone he
has his own IG l can't stop with yeah I
can't believe never seen him dance dance
moves right no I didn't know you could
dance you can actually dance I get for a
comedian I'm pretty did you see already
dance what did not I just I was really
into Michael Jackson as a kid and my
joke is like I was good but luckily not
good enough to get it get on his radar
good enough for the neighborhood but not
good enough that he hears about it a
continent away
here's world that bullet buddy no [ __ ]
yeah here go down yeah play though that
one right yeah right there see what that
is about you know
you're tried different one there's a
problem
keep going that's what he would do do do
you have any children yourself
you look like Razor Ramon there's nobody
membrane it'd be like 30 people in the
audience right yeah he would always go
on like a midnight train go back to his
profile oh [ __ ] dude can we play this
one then well then I'll move on to play
they might play the one where he's in
the gene jack there which have you seen
this one Cal no oh that's what Melissa
this is my friends I know let me refresh
other goes wait me Falls this one's so
good I'll get up in this game paper
yeah we can show this right this is yeah
this is more melissa was on us yes you
got a background the other one well
let's see
who is that in more severe signore I
love
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sket I got expelled me from being too
rebellious more travels fast so what you
like to live here now
practice if you want to be the best
there's a whole world of dance out there
that you don't even know about what it's
such an 80s vibe it's so it's really
well shot yeah eres no no
Aristotle like the theorists see the
stand-up ended director and really so
good yeah Akiva really good who is he
the Aristotle
so he is he's in goat face like we
started doing videos together
and like he could do so much with no
money like this is just YouTube day oh
my god okay okay yeah I wanted to do a
no mosh like break-in and like all those
80s dance with me
[Music]
this is such an eighties vibe right it
looks like a terrible eighties movie I
just have $30 take it we only had one
shot at it the whole point is like those
movies I would grow up watching them you
know and they oh yeah they would always
it was almost like who's these white
characters who are the central
characters yeah I'm gonna take you to
the inner city show you how they do it
here yeah and it's like they were just
like visiting like it's a zoo or
something then they would go back to
their white lives be like check it out I
know I know the black yeah true so I
wanted to recreate that but then show
how removed they are from that world
where like they're having a good time
but he's afraid of like the people he's
dancing with really well shot and edited
yeah Ariston was great so like it was a
great partnership because I would do a
lot of videos on my own before I met him
just the ideas were always there it's
very DIY and he always loved them and he
was like oh I'm a pretty good I do
videos and stuff but he didn't have any
body of work he stopped doing it for a
long time
Wow no way yeah he's in LA he's like my
UCB he's like in Franklin Village yeah
so like doing he's doing this he's doing
directing and comedy and writing and
stuff full-time but this is when we were
huddling around you know like runts and
he liked my stuff and he was like if I
direct and you write and then we just
started making some magic together
that's cool man yeah that's cool you've
doubled down on video since quarantine
you know what's crazy is like something
when you think about your career and
stuff it's all happenstance like I
didn't design it like this but when
stand-up was going on I would
a lot of stand-up and I would do some
sketch when I had an idea on IG but now
this is all there is no this is my only
stage yeah so I've just been like going
harder on this cuz that's it kind of
takes the guesswork out of how to split
your time yeah and the response has been
pretty good yeah thanks man no I'll come
over yeah I'll do it camión I was gonna
turn my house into a studio like it's
paramount law and it's the most low-rent
sketch go [ __ ] ham in the corner um
yeah they're so [ __ ] funny what a
dumb idiot went on unbroken did he say
when oh yeah when it's gonna open up he
say anything he said in weddings maybe
July
what do you mean that like August or
July and I mean it was on Rogan yeah he
did his podcast yeah Oh sounds like you
don't approve sounds like you don't know
who it is
I don't know Adam well he wrote he's the
talent coordinator for the commies Oh
Adam oh [ __ ] yeah I know Adam I know his
last name of the egit oh you did well
yeah I guess you did they say when
they're gonna open because because now
they're saying churches are back
essential businesses are back I'm pretty
sure gyms are back but gyms are back the
ball they can only allow certain amount
of people and I think I think you're
right yeah
yeah so you got a figure you know that
in restaurants you're gonna start coming
back wouldn't you consider comes to a
rest but it's basically a restaurant I
know the stage if you want cheers
there's food
yeah there's a cookies and Ebro isn't
fries order the chicken fingers fries
this I don't know your laws I think it
falls into cabaret Club cabaret even
when it opens up what do you think
that's gonna be like that twenty five
percent capacity
no because thing about the the main room
holds 300 yeah the Oh our whole company
75 no one that like 150 I think no a war
yeah 150 the belly rooms like 75 for 15
other rooms like 80 okay
yeah 80 I'm sorry
I don't know but you guys have shows
coming up pretty soon like we leave
tomorrow oh [ __ ] that's it you wanna
Houston dude I think every show we have
a sold out yeah
whether it's Houston spoke in Arizona
yeah that's pretty cool
you know what the capacity is on these
Houston's actually kind of banging 65%
whoa see that's a big 50 it's yeah I'm
psyched to 72 well I have 300 people
there each show yep six shows oh yeah
I realize they wear that tomorrow night
yeah tomorrow I see me a little weird
yeah I've missed them so long I was
gonna this morning I was going over my
set on my you're like what what did I
care about issues like that I care about
once again and up is the one thing that
you can't really take time off you will
feel at the gym is what we have no
technology for yeah we've had no choice
I grew with you can't they if you take a
week off and then I do a set like if I
did a weekend and then do a show at the
main room Tuesday night I knew I was
gonna be sharp Tuesday night yeah if I
took two weeks off and just set like in
the belly room honking oh it was almost
embarrassed that we can like you know be
like oh I always think about this guy I
think was you Chuck Perlman meet the
greatest violinist of all time like
classical violinist and like classical
violin is like [ __ ] one of those like
your classical piano is like they
practiced like their life is that you
don't do anything else right yeah and he
said he said I never forgot he said he
said if I take if I take a day off
practice you know the I notice if I take
two days off my conductor notices if I
take three days off the audience notices
yeah and that might be annexed might be
an extreme example but I think that's
fair but yeah but like just lose it use
my positions and just and then also
having fun yes if I know if I know my
you know my my our I know whatever the
15 minute seven do I could have I'm
allowed that more fun yeah without
thinking about you like everything is
like that I feel like you know I feel
like if you were podcasting like if you
take you know sports certainly if you
take two to three weeks off podcasting
they come back to little you know yeah
yeah your shadow the roof even just the
minor you can make these like my new SH
and adjustments you know but like not
taking this much time off it's
what do I wonder what was I talking
about do I even care about that thing
well that's that's the other thing do I
care what is it just seems so trivial in
the grand scheme of things right now so
yeah I'm very curious there's an hour of
roasting people of masks on get a word I
don't know we're gonna find out tomorrow
are people gonna wear black masks no no
oh really I was thinking that we
separate cat camps I think might be some
people wearing on right yeah I think so
too I don't with our demo
18:36 bros probably not a lot of masks
ya know if your demo shows that all my
[ __ ] parents how about my dad 80 we
haven't talked yeah so so I gotta see my
father for his 80th birthday we shoot a
round of golf
he couldn't be killing it more he's just
doing great but the [ __ ] guy kept
coming close to me and I go hey you
gotta I got tested and I'm negative hmm
I got a swab actually got you know not
really going your brain yeah but
actually now they can do it on surface
so I came back negative
my sister came back negative but my dad
and my mom are like coming over and
they're like like three inches away
it was then I kept going hey I just
plain and also outright sit still you
days nothing well it takes two days
right to get the thing so home you know
just in case
but he's 80 and he's in a high altitude
and and if he gets it he could be in
[ __ ] real trouble Big Mike's yeah
they're both 80 you know yeah yeah and
and he's got he's got a heart he's got a
tribute fibrillation some [ __ ] and one
it would be bad and he's [ __ ]
overweight so um but the [ __ ]
goes I go
dude I go hey back off and he goes like
this he goes oh yeah I forgot you're one
of those I love it oh my come on dude
I love it anyway meanwhile though he
spends all his time outside playing golf
he's he couldn't even that's it that's
it and and they just stole my mother
back you know like seven bananas they
had a party I was the youngest person
there I stayed the [ __ ] away from
everybody but I didn't does away from me
they were all like you were I was scared
they weren't and you know what they said
a lot a lot I'm more like you know what
I'm 80 I don't have time to be this
cautious I gotta live my life and
there's no there are no cases up there
it's been a good run there are no cases
are there but I didn't want to be the
one to bring it there and kill the whole
[ __ ] party
all right you know I was thinking about
that really they weren't they weren't
careful it was just so funny man yeah it
was it was wild is your fun yes it was
[ __ ] great it was great to see a man
at 80 and people were making speeches
about him and like his life rose to them
in his way hey what are you know
roasting him there was just like you
know you you you've expanded my life
you've been so generous you neither
roared they use for my dad the most was
generous that's good that's [ __ ] cool
I mean while the guy hasn't lost a
[ __ ] ounce of his wits is he's still
losing it what the dude I forget about
about the greatest service talking about
China and how they're taking over and
everything else my father's listening
who's spent his whole life in
international banking and in China any
sinner like this and he's like and my
sisters like another thing about China
and how they're taken over and
everything else
my father quietly goes I don't subscribe
to that point of view but he does it
that's my no no that's my cue to go you
don't miss me oh yes I mean I know this
is the popular thing that you see I knew
this gonna have to make money and and
then I go well what do you mean you
don't think Chinese are threatening us
no I don't I don't they innovate exactly
nothing let's just start with that
second of all the idea that they are
have influence in the world do you have
any idea and he went through what
they're facing economically what
problems they have economically and how
they failed over and over again in
influencing the United Nations yeah even
though they spend money it was just
interesting to you don't you forget
Savannah has their own problems de Pape
was also bitter at Oakdale Papa's been
around but Papa spent a lot of time in
those place for your parents cared for
you yeah I love my parents there in
Seattle right now so yeah talking about
Mahalo she's like much more concerned
the whole are they dad 71 mom like 65 do
you speak Darian or anything uh poorly I
can be like Salaam she told us to you
know but like anything so when a person
person speaks do you understand him
Farsi I mean my parents could because I
think dialect is a little different but
like they can understand each other but
for me it's hard enough understanding
dari so once you throw some like Persian
accent on it it's never do your parents
want you to marry
then your I do you think they would
prefer but I don't think it's like
necessary I don't think yeah
well your honor that much you're a comic
so that's the other thing too it's like
how much do you it depends how much you
care about that thing you know what I
mean like maybe I'm very American like I
like I do stand-up I yeah yes you're
also a comic I'm also comics she's also
another country pretty much I really
know what it is yeah I think all of them
save for games on his own Island yeah I
would agree with you
yes seems never you know normal dude you
know even though Mike's comics yeah what
is that how your brain works
thank God just a different atom thank
God that's what makes you the colors
good and I would imagine if you took it
tally of all the comics of comics or who
the funniest guy is you'd be the guy
that's nice that's why I would have I
would assume it so and that's always
been like kind of what's been getting me
through my career and all and I've
always had that like support and love
from the comics but the commercial
success is always kind of eluded me now
things are kind of picking up yeah like
in the last year or two I've been in the
game for a long time so just like I'd
always hear like oh man you're so funny
you're so underrated or I don't get it
why not my career my whole that's been
me oh I'm gonna jump on Fahim that's all
I got well 400,000 people will watch a
sudden you know you've got invited we'll
listen what I'm saying is that - no as
always I always heard you're you know
you're under the radar nobody knows you
you know you see me should be working
remember when I was your age I wasn't
working you aren't no dude but I think
you've been working for so long had a
Stoli now hold you I'll take thirty say
maybe I'm a year old when I was 36 I
believe I was doing I was recurring on a
show called seventh heaven I was I was
referring but it didn't mean I was on
there I'm gonna have you call Craig he's
like a huge seventh heaven
you just shut up for me for my friend I
did do seven episodes of fat actress
MADtv before that when I was 28 Bubba
but still doing some big break yeah I
mean you know a big sale wouldn't you
win you're in the eye of the storm you
can't see it for what it is you know why
even these are great things but I think
when you're living it yeah yours like uh
you know what I mean Bobby you know I've
been like I've been I'm in luck
yeah yeah but like Brendan and I always
like you know don't feel what I guess
what I'm trying to say is you're you're
the good news is that you're really
talented and very unique and original
yeah thanks and and and it says it will
find you and I you have to be patient
and 36 is [ __ ] young for him yeah
since he's 13 you know 18 no you study
engineering yeah I know yeah yeah yeah I
made that up not Boeing yeah I throw
that around yeah but I've never
confirmed it but but I'm saying is that
yeah I guess I I'm very zen about it now
just cuz like you know I love that quote
from Seinfeld where he's like a career
is a very long time and the grand scheme
of things who cares like as long as you
get there and all that but I think when
you're like a younger comic it's like
you want it yesterday but then things
play out and once you love comedy you
love comedy doesn't really matter and
it's all a wash but artistically I've
always been very fulfilled but the thing
that always escaped me was the
commercial success but I don't see my
friends pop off like yeah I do and
daliyah and all these guys and and it's
well deserving all that but everyone's
path is so different is realizing I mean
but then also then you also look at a
guy like you know Lucy Kay how long was
he doing before you forever yeah or ever
you know I know he's always the cool guy
who was really talented but well he's
got on a comics respect yes they knew
how I remember what about mark Normand I
mean he's getting there he's on his way
Seinfield has him open up for him that's
what time when he comes to joke writing
like this there's nobody protect me
every there's nobody better yeah mark
really cool to see these guys break the
model even like you guys in just the
power of direct to the fans like mark
Normand special also you know what
Schulz was doing and then also who else
Sam Sam RL his special well like these
are really talented guys in the stand-up
scene and they just couldn't
get in from these gatekeepers you know
yeah and like we can everyone anyone
anyone who does stand-up knows like
these are some one of the tough like
some of the top guy I know what it's
like it's like when you it's like in the
NBA it's like a guy in practice just
lighting people up like dude that that
guy's scored 30 points on you know
curcumin Durant in practice every day
but he just needs a shot to get the goal
it's in the game and that yours the six
man comes off the bench makes you know
your James Harden weren't there fighters
like that would you say well there are
guys in the gym detectors but that's
different because for him it's not like
when there's a big stage for him doesn't
perform right
there's fighters in gyms where you're
like you know they're getting to the top
and you're like dude I've never seen him
lose around and he just beat up this the
UFC heavyweight champion the world beat
his ass for five rounds who the [ __ ] are
they gonna toss them and then he gets to
you have seen he's fighting like a
mediocre guy but the lights are hot and
he's never been in there and he gets
knocked down like the [ __ ] dude so you
just don't have it when it comes time
you don't have it mentally yeah like
there's scrimmage Kings yeah it's like
the guy in practice you know yeah yeah
but then when it when it counts when all
the chips are on the line they don't
show yeah it's not like that with
stand-ups really not like that because
yeah if you're at the store it's that I
mean dude you're like the people you're
got your sandwich in between what's in a
way it's like the toughest away game so
then if we I'm sure when you go on the
road it's like that's what I noticed
about the store like once I became a
part of that family and I got past and I
got to use that gym if you take a
fraction of what you learned from the o
R or the Comedy Store and you do the
road anywhere else it's like shooting
fish in a barrel it's just so potent
you're swingin with five bats yeah I
think Rogan says so I almost still is
cool but it's like the comic stores like
running with a weighted vest on totally
and then when you get you get on the
road you take it off you might have a
heckler like you kidding me did you see
I it's God he's gotten a lot easier I've
seen this and I also have in the wings
Joey Diaz Joe Rogan bill burr Bryan
Callen Fahim and Chris D'Elia
Yvonne where if I don't roast you I
would get
I'm gonna light your ass up not because
I want to because I don't want to go
back and see those guys yeah yeah yeah
it's gotten easier the story used to be
when you have for whatever reason member
they or when there was nobody yeah yeah
I've known it would be it was so true
like if you could do we we should always
say if you can do the o.r on a Tuesday
at 11 o'clock at night you can do
anywhere on the planet and that was so
true because it would be dark and it'd
be just [ __ ] and and it would sort
of have you'd have people like certain
some like you'd have some foreigners but
for the most part it was just yeah
people chatting trickling in honoring
your set some people leave especially
obviously so much newer than you guys
you know where have my toughest set that
is that the improv a Late Show at the
home yeah you know why I I marry I marry
everyone was eating dick and I went in
on and ate all the dicks and then D'Elia
got up there and I was like man this was
the tough that means that good comics
wait great comics before me everyone
ain't dick yeah and I was like man I
delete about to eat some dick and I what
I went dude that's tough when he's like
okay it goes up then it was like half
full he's like you just take the second
there's deadlines in extraneous you fit
more people in my treehouse
it just started rose to the oh yeah and
then just set him on fire
yeah I'd that show at that was a via
10:00 p.m. and then I was on the
midnight show and I was in my car and he
come becomes buying us what are you
doing he knocks I go I don't want to go
back in there he goes you're gonna get
back in there you called me about I did
he was called me he goes you're gonna
get back in and this is comedy you
didn't get back in there he's you know
many times we've all been there I mean
if you're gonna get back in there I'm
gonna go back in and I just I know he
going about Mary Mary go oh geez I but
you know that night like late night at
The Improv
for whatever reason there are a lot of
hot young gals and their boyfriends and
whenever I see that in that group I'm
always like you guys are there's
something about this to energy I thought
yeah I want that makes it not colleague
about ice you know I you know I said
this whole mix um but I still do it's a
lot better now but I was just trying it
out that night should I didn't want to
do I said some about ice and again some
hot young Mexican girls in the front row
with her giant steroid boyfriend I said
some shoes you know [ __ ] you and took
ice right at me yeah I was like oh sure
it's very strange yeah the lab is the
worst I mean I'll do it just to like
work some stuff out or like say some
words out loud but it's it's like the
comedy Bermuda Triangle nothing
have you ever had a good set in the lab
you know I think they're getting rid of
the bar it's problem with the lab is
it's like the stage there but then
there's a bar to be who getting drinks
and like talking to your sits just on
your next to it look dude no one really
gets into but I think that I like that a
weird Fung Shui would set you at I'm
like I'm a store and I get the factory
of them and in the liveness well you
didn't let that piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
the lamp is a cover mirror come from
David I'll calls me this yeah I gotta go
downtown I got to do this Jewish this
Jewish group that wanted to stand up but
I gotta have you because you can get
them going I can't get these people
going right away so I need somebody with
energy I go I'll come down right now
I'll give you a give you 400 bucks or I
don't know what the [ __ ] they're Panem I
go you don't give me money I'll just
come down with you there's no I'm gonna
all right so I get there and I walk in
and it's a bar
it's a [ __ ] bar and they're there
it's noisy as [ __ ] cuz it's after work
and it's happy hour and it's a happy
hour bar corporate bar whoo okay well
where we gonna just stand up upstairs go
upstairs we go upstairs I look around
they go well I can hear them because I'm
upstairs but there's if it's a balcony
so I look over I can hear that oh no
that's cool no no don't worry because
we're gonna get people to come up and I
go where's the sound system he he pulls
out you know one of those boxes those
amplifiers that you would use for your
electric guitar a few like you're on the
subway so I go that's what you have and
he goes yeah and the kind the [ __ ]
goes can't and plugs in a mic so I go
where's the stage and the guy goes well
we don't have a stage
but maybe you could use this couch this
is a true story anyway does it true
story so I got the couch now ready it
was a children's couch it was a it was a
couch that was this big you mini futon
it was that was it you know it was the
kind of couch you put your dog on yeah
you buy it in a dog in a pet store it's
a dog couch so I go so I I get up on the
couch now here's what you don't realize
Brennan the ceiling was low so it was
touching my head soaked this people come
up and I decide to open up with and
they're all sitting on the floor cuz
there's nowhere to sit you understand oh
yeah grown man and then and it was a
Jewish for a Jewish charity of some kind
and that's how we did stand-up how the
show goes
oh it went so great they're like oh
great oh dude it went great
yeah I had to open so that was fantastic
I don't mind those corporate gigs why
because everybody was talking downstairs
and it was so it was offensive
I'm sure you've had some tough ones yeah
but if they throw enough money at you
it's like who gives a [ __ ] one time my
brother my brother somehow orchestrated
this crazy corporate gig for me he was
golfing with some guy who like owns a
bunch of toyota dealerships in Seattle
and he's like alright so I just it's
funny the way he was bullshitting - he
loved playing golf and he's like yeah my
brother you know he's not he's a
stand-up he's at the Comedy Store and he
acts you could look at his IMDB and you
know normally his rate is he's just
bullshitting like and he gets me like
forty five hundred for it or something
for 30 minutes of stand I'm coming heard
some Toyota a Christmas party thing I'm
like of course so I go there and it's
just not set up for comedy it's like
lunch room tables you know the circle
just super bright
there's buffets people are mingling and
stuff and they don't music is okay
because you could passively enjoy that I
have to go up after this band and they
just want to talk to each other so I'm
up there just like talking to a wall of
sound and they're all talking they're
not paying attention and I'm just like
on autopilot there's no way the 30 yeah
because in my mind I'm like all I gotta
do is not
snap and I collect my check yeah all I
have to do is put on a smile go through
the motions and if anyone wants to tune
in they'll get a show this is this guy's
blunder not mine
you know his people didn't want comma
data so I just kind of like paced back
and forth do my thing for 30 minutes eat
[ __ ] and then the guy has to budging Lee
write a check to he's like how much was
that yeah I'm like nice doing business I
would do that over and over I guess yeah
I did I did a wedding in San Diego same
situation same situation then I did the
Riverkeepers you know what that is huh
bring up Riverkeepers benefit a very
minute fishing giggle thing called you
filmed it you'll go this way that's
nothing about five years ago yeah that
was terrible Brennan just wrote Jesus
but I did River Riverkeepers which is an
amazing thing for a Bobby Kennedy I had
done this this thing in at the biggest
house a government official league Bobby
Kennedy yeah so I did he come up to me I
did that everybody was there everybody
huge was there in LA I killed it that
guy and I I did really well and he came
up and he said can you do that can you
do that again and I said yeah I'm a
comic I crushed it like with all these
famous people Lincoln Park was there and
I I [ __ ] destroyed it was great they
there it was like this it was in this in
this tent but it was in LA at this
biggest house so whatever I hit when I
did I do well yeah and every celebrity
is their enemy so he comes up me because
can you do that for me at the
Riverkeepers I get there in New York
it's 1,100 people in an airplane hangar
it's 1,100 people in an airplane hangar
and they put me up when people were
eating and talking and I had to do
stand-up a lot of white oh no no was
blue collared Union guys oh yeah I ate I
ate such a dagger and this is when I was
like doing great
I ate such a dick I when I think about
it I get embarrassed when I think about
it you know his wheel - everybody came
dude everybody came when I know he
wasn't there he was dead by then a
picture of when I can't well no dude Oh
Chelsea Clinton was there everybody was
there what are you talking about
everybody's that I think Hillary had
when Hillary was there
what are you still mingling and [ __ ] or
you get out I ran away I actually went
to my room and I wouldn't leave and
Bobby called me and said you impressed a
lot of people today he was such a nice
guy
he felt me so bad yeah Bobby right there
he's great I think that's his name Bobby
Kennedy but dude I ain't walking lazy I
mean such a Power Move - you're like
named Bobby Kennedy in front of 1100
people I ran away Arnold was there
everybody dude everybody I ate all the
dicks in front of everyone everybody and
one guy came up to me I thought I was
funny one guy I wouldn't leave me alone
what was his name doesn't matter
Bobby Kennedy I cringe when I think
about it I I've there's nothing worse
than being a comic and doing and eating
all the dicks in front of 1,100 people
in New York City and while a
professional hockey player who's a
legend Cameron Bure his name introduces
you and then goes like this you come off
and he goes tough gig a tough one well
well you saw Tim Tebow think you have
worried all the six-way listen Tim Tebow
and all the dicks I've eaten all the
dicks late I don't do any of these
things anymore I know you don't smoke
Jays wife had that every year they have
they would I think they fly to Santa
Barbara or Marina del Rey I forget where
but there was half a comic open up and
they've hired the biggest comics yeah
they had a comic come in there I think
it was Aziz Ansari and he gets there and
you know he you know he does this thing
they give him the stage he just looked
around and I guess you just start
roasting everybody just started lighting
him up and destroyed but before they
everyone ate dicks yeah dicks
but with Bryan with Tim Tebow so Tim
with Tim is to get buddy and he has this
Tim Tim Tebow charity event where
there's golf and there's a whole
Foundation and I've been through it like
five years in a row and they always have
these awful comedians open up and they
eat [ __ ] I know dude you need a real
comedian I'll get you a real comedian
yes yeah go yeah my boy Brian I'd do it
he's like yeah but isn't Brian like a
little dirty oh no Brian that's clean
material so I called Brian Mackay I can
get you we will fly out first class all
the stuff but it has to be like clean
material dude you can't have anything
that no dick grab and know that
everybody can't do come on professional
I got this
this dude goes up there's I see kids
sick kids sick kids know they're on the
last leg it's like literally mom their
cart
in the back like everybody hears Bryan
Callen that baby rolls up the kids are
on their ventilators the whole works I'm
like don't [ __ ] this up right and I'm
sitting there and Tim's brother Robbie
I'm really good friends was like hey you
see me good right yeah I've got over it
man he's good man and they go okay
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
say prayer and then we'll bring up Bryan
I wish I would I'd rather you say prayer
and I do something and then bring up
Bryan he's like dude that's all we have
time for so they say prayer everyone you
know everyone super religious then he
goes down I write up a chance together
for Bryan count Bryan gets up then it's
a super religious group and Bryan goes
well one thing you know Jesus is a lot
better at a number of things than me one
thing is not funnier than me the Lions
cricket up here like they don't get
literally a well Tim Tim is like but
yeah my Mayer loved it he was like can
you come talk to my boys I'm like I'm
not doing any of this [ __ ] I'm never
doing Santa ever again like this this is
that was it was these are great
opportunities than mingle with these
type of people but very rarely does it
go well I always the best when they come
to the store Oh governor governor on you
and you see sick kids in the audience
yeah now I got a tailor my [ __ ] right
away I get I I shouldn't put you in that
now if you didn't know you didn't know I
I was a girl the commissary honey what
the list like you I would have been fine
if I'd gone for it but I was well if
they let you do your thing yeah but I
could it's very hard to like get
yourself in real time yes gig yeah but
what else is crazy like people don't
realize like why don't people do these
corporate gigs when you find out how
much some of these comics again for a
corporate gig how to blow your mind now
blow your mind yeah it's not one you
seek them out but if it lands in your
lap you're like yeah I guess some do
though I know some really big comics ooh
that's you know they do a lot of
corporate gigs and they pick [ __ ] you
know talkin six-figure pay raise am I
crazy there for 30 minutes yeah
but again you're you're tailing their
super clean comics they're tailing
towards the ground
yes it's purely a money play and if
that's your thing that's great but yeah
I I feel like I'm being rented and I
feel like I'm compromising it for the
wrong reason
you're doing [ __ ] for the wrong reason
you're always gonna feel like I'm lying
when I'm up there think about Michelle
woof
think about the balls no punt it
the balls are when they go hey want you
to speak at the at the White House and I
guess I heard her talk about this I
forget where but she was like I'm gonna
do this and I don't need all the dicks
in the room but the comics out there and
everybody see this she's gonna love it
so she goes as I'm doing in my head I'm
thinking about other people not the
people in the room yeah she's there's
two audiences sometimes when you do
things like that there's the audience in
the room and the audience who are
consuming it on a screen so it's like
she was she was looking for the Internet
that's what she was she was patron the
Internet and like other comics watching
not in the room to have you watch it
yeah I mean the room people are just
like yeah she was great that she I was
supposed to write on Hassan was doing it
again this year and I was gonna be on
the writing team for it but then on the
White House for the yeah for the
correspondence thing but then corona hit
and it put the brakes on it so I mean
that would have been a fun thing to do
like I've always wanted to do that she's
that I like her so much cuz I don't even
know her and I saw her in New York at
the Comedy Cellar and she saw me she was
high and she gave me a hug I was like
what a [ __ ] sweepers yeah I saw your
back room with the the the story got
real nervous just kind of like
disappeared into the night he says
sweetie I don't know what she said well
comments she's a real comic yeah it took
some balls because you know you're going
down in flames in the room there's gonna
be a hero to half yeah
you ever see uh stephen colbert's that's
one of my favorites like Stephen
Colbert's White House Correspondents
Dinner speech is like one of my
favorites that kind of started the whole
year just like during Obama's right he's
not as much as he's was Bush [ __ ]
amazing
you know The Colbert lost his two
brothers and his father in a plane crash
yeah it's the same time his family and
then some his family died too I thought
most two brothers and his father hmm
and then maybe someone else I don't know
that's crazy but he's so funny
Colbert was it's so good he's so good
he's so good you don't get better than
that you know Mitch and he did strangers
the can do no Colbert
what a beast I'd be nervous to do
something like that that's not my thing
when wouldn't you think you're gonna go
back on the road damn I think everyone's
waiting to see if me and Brian died yeah
yeah we're feeling you're like comics
texting me so many clear eros Schultz
okay everyone I mean I'm gonna text you
and c-e-o everyone's like dude let's
keep us posted I was like let me know
man I'm my mama like what do you guys
think is gonna happen I got a Dallas I
got San Antonio I got a we get to him
we're gonna I'm gonna feel it out you
know oh I'm not like trying to be on the
frontlines why not do it yeah you're
afraid not afraid I kind of care more
about spots opening up around town in LA
I like popping around doing 15 minutes
oh I would trade everything we're doing
for the store dope yeah yeah I'd much
rather be I don't want to travel or
vines open I'm scared of it I just don't
the one thing I learned the one good
thing for me that killest quarantines I
work too much man
I listen so much [ __ ] I wake up every
morning my kids I put my kid to bed
every night I mean I've spent so much
time with my kids and my other son boss
and he's he just turned six months and
I'm going I haven't missed anything
I've missed nothing with him and I don't
remember any it with my son Tiger
because I was always on the road I
wasn't when he was first born I was in
Australia I was in Dublin I was you know
I was just giving the stand up so I was
on the road show so much and then now I
have a boss I'm like holy [ __ ] this is
so cool my girls like you missed all
this now - that ain't happen again so I
called Justin yes I'm like dude we ain't
doing those three weekends in a row
anymore
he's like even just for the year like no
dude I'm not doing that anymore I'm
missing too much [ __ ] I I mean I'm gone
four out of the seven days of the week
and when I land I'm a [ __ ] vegetable
because I've been going hard the pain
and stand up I take a 6:00 a.m. flight I
land in LA at 10:00 a.m. I'm tired have
no rest and the people like oh that's
your day off and then Monday have two
podcasts and then I'll do a set at night
Tuesday - podcast set that night
Wednesday set that night podcast
Thursday on the plane and that's kind of
one no it's important that you say that
because I I did my whole my daughters
whole childhood was that for me and I
have so much regret for it I have so
much good I'm making up for it now but
it was a mother [ __ ] and she knows it
and she remembered kids no she
remembered I missed five of her
birthdays and she remembers that they
say when a kid turns five
if they did all this research winter kid
turns five if you weren't there you
didn't make a connection there you can
never make that up yeah there's
something that goes on there the
connection was like an avatar horse with
that connection one that is it you can
even be a good dad and make up but
there's there's the certain thing that
you're gonna miss sound that the kid it
doesn't make the connection for the rest
of its life yeah yeah I think everyone
this break has made everyone realized
what's important to them and what's not
like you learn what you can live without
and what's really important yeah yeah so
I mean that's good that is good
there's always something good something
bad you know mm-hmm but you don't tour
like crazy anyway for Hema you know I'm
in this we're not a road we are cleaning
as a road dog like I'm a headliner you
know and I'll pop out when it makes
sense but I'm in this weird kind of like
cusp area of my career where it's like
things are going well but I'm not at the
rate where it makes sense for me to be
on the road it's not like I'm leaving a
ton of money on the table by not doing
the road I have to feature at this point
even though no oh
headline like I'll do what I'm gonna do
I did like how many on state and there's
some clubs that I like doing that
they're just fun to do even if the
money's kind of okay there's fun cities
yeah yeah so yeah I'm not dying you're
also in a weird spot too cuz it's like
well now it's a little different but if
I you know be tough for to have you as a
feature well that's the problem is
you're a headliner but you're in a weird
economic position we're totally but you
could do like a co like thing know you
somebody who who's selling my super are
like theater guys I could feature or it
makes sense like feel like you and dilly
it'd be a great show yeah that'd be fun
I was doing it with Neil for everything
with Neil
when Neil was doing his theater shows I
was opening for him there you have to
have a [ __ ] monster behind you no I'm
saying like if you just totally yeah
someone who's just kind of like content
in their own success stories already
there just as like cream guys this Fahim
yes yeah like some kind of cap some
width because if it's just like another
headliner who's like pretty good but
doesn't have any recognition hasn't
taken out I think we were supposed to he
was gonna like take me on some dates
before aronia hit yeah yeah but that
would be cool - yeah
no matter the closest weird kind of
in-between spot
we're like artistically I'm I'm like in
a good place and but just career-wise
it's kind of catching up - you want it
you want to act obviously do you want to
be on shows I mean the dream is like I
love guys like Ricky Gervais Soleri
David but like stand-up is a strong
thing of mine to wear I want to write
create and act in my own stuff and still
do stand-up or like you know Louie yeah
yeah don't show everything yeah just
wear you you get to wear all the hats
Maron - what's that Miriam here - yeah
great yes guys my advice would be to
pair up though with somebody who has a
track record in TV and understands the
structure of TV because a lot of people
make the mistake including you I'm sorry
but it's true
I've only been around too long that a
lot of comics think they can write a TV
show no you can't yeah you can't
TV show that will actually work yeah
because - actually yeah because there
are too many little details that you
don't understand that I'm talking about
myself I agree to this I subscribe yeah
you have to wait you answer distracting
I know you have they're not they're
off-white the cream but I you have to be
with somebody that has a track record
that understands not only what the
network wants at this particular moment
has a relationship with them and also
can write that it's that x-factor that's
hard to put your finger on well it's
like stand-up it's a very specific thing
I can't just assume that I'm gonna know
how to write a TV show and this guy
we've been doing the eye remover you've
been doing it his whole life
right like I'll have funny ideas and
[ __ ] but I know that you need a
structure person someone who knows the
formula who knows where this for
instance enough
I know I know stand-up and I know sketch
everything else yeah my wit knee with 2
broke girls Whitney was a writer with
patrick michael patrick king who was the
head writer and the essentially the
showrunner of Sex in the City Michael
Patrick King is a [ __ ] monster writer
so you need to always pair up with
somebody like that and you could because
you have a great imagination but yeah
yeah I think that's good advice
yeah hearing up it's good advice for any
comic I see a lot of comics I'm not
gonna do it all yeah I get sent these
scripts and I'm like and I do it - I did
it for years I make the mistake it's
it's just not how you read that's good
forever remember after I spent you know
when I read it know what I would do
differently is that wouldn't spend on it
I'm trying to be a writer I am a comic
just good right yeah man that's an
appeal with a writer and you have ideas
and they put it to yes like so you're
not spinning your wheels you're not ears
but also it's hard to really reach that
power because you know because usually
especially as a comic or podcast you're
making on your own like I'll just figure
you have to realize yeah you can say
that but if nothing's getting done and
you keep on saying you're gonna do this
thing and it never does delegate yeah I
know that's not your strong suit and
lean into what is your strong that's
right that was my biggest I wasted more
time doing that I can't even tell you I
spent years and I'm not kidding years in
time our writing that's writing writing
writing yet never work I think my
biggest pitfall like when I was coming
up was I just love new jokes I'm always
chasing the next bit so even on
important shows I would kind of I would
just chase the bit you know I wouldn't
try to do well on the show do you know
that would crush you do a new bit yeah I
just kind of wanted to chase the newest
idea of course when maybe for this show
I should be trying to impress rather
than like serve that thing for me yeah
that's a really knowing what to do on
what show was like a huge game changer
for me I'm like oh I could do those bits
at a shitty open mic I don't have to
like try this one joke on the config
showcases yeah yeah so like knowing what
to do on what show and like tailoring
your material was like a big
breakthrough that make sense yeah I'm a
big believer in just if you get
undeniable and you get your crushing
rooms over and over and you live in LA
someone's gonna see you someone sees you
yeah well that's how everything's been
happening in the past like a year or two
is just like guys in the room saying
like Rogen singing or or like you know
I've known Tulia forever that's how I
got at the store
I got people nuts story like um correct
me if I'm wrong I'm pretty sure Delia
brought you and he D'Elia got you passed
and Theo passed you know that and I
won't feel past the battery yeah yeah
that's right we have to stop for a
second
chin edit I just realized I [ __ ] said
it here's the good news on it
6 is 50% off 50% off to work out on my
house yes I'll have to
going off to go to gym OPS's get cooties
off to wear mask that their classes he
knows you're the math yeah it states the
future it really is amazing you don't
worry about anything on it six on demand
training do it from the comfort of your
home your garage your hotel room where
the hell you want to work out as long as
you not touch anybody well they gotta
calm slash fighter tempers off the
entire site but 50% off on-demand
training they got barbells they got on
it stinks barbell on a six body weight
on our six kettlebell on at six steel
mace streaming fitness in general it's
crazy and looking more you guys want me
and what more do you want
what temp stuff supplements nutrition
apparel Bob would do it for your mouth
man he not at docs Tom's last fighter
temp sent off get you some I know you
didn't I didn't know you said that
during those get to our meeting old
old that happened an hour and a half ago
that was where am I Chico Han Jin Jin
Who am I VLA juggle what so we just add
just stop it's Sunday I just I just off
this show I just have to show and I told
my to edit something that I said because
there's information I found out and I
thought you were gonna say hey edit out
where I said I waste a lot of my life
writing because machi I'm actually
trying to do script path I don't want
people to know that I wasted a lot of my
life edit that I have a motivational
book coming out and I don't that was so
no I I said told chin added something
out that I had said it to Brendan when I
was two hours ago when we weren't
recording
he was the middle story oh I don't
remember that
forgetting a lot of [ __ ] checked out
yeah and I'm pretty sure the the top
commie spot in Seattle shut down do you
know that the world parlour yes already
that was already great club news not ran
well yeah it was already a pool hall
like yeah it was like a bowl to me it
was already a sort of transition period
is about they need a club they have one
down now they have that last lesson of
the U District
yeah but down downtown Seattle Hall copy
underground yeah commenting on Pioneer
Square they need like a real [ __ ]
spot mate cuz you have you have a spot
in Tacoma yeah yeah so can that's not
really see how different markets yeah
Seattle Seattle needs a real Club it's
amazing how many big cities actually
don't have legit like like Chicago is
proper it has the Laugh Factory but
that's it no Chicago's nothing there was
a great small of a laugh factor which
are great spots as far as like a like a
big room like the Houston improv or yeah
you know as a knees and astral then
happen he is crazy like a wise guy they
have a factory in Chicago though they
have a laugh at you but you would you go
would you well the factories you can
down yeah they don't have headliners
they have like Wyeth around I guess you
know it's like they don't have that big
headliner comic there they have their
thing they have all the theaters in the
world well Chicago is a show expense is
the epicenter Steppenwolf theater
company second city yeah I mean it's an
improv huge tradition huge improvin
theer car well they also have the
Chicago theater there yes we're doing in
January now with Santina only night show
that's gonna be a lot of fun I don't
know you don't jump on this thing man
I'm here you do it yeah of course fine
well talks talk that yes my man let me
say I'm crazy we don't have money but we
do have drugs and good a lot of
attitudes and brands never forget your
name I did not a deal okay give it up
for him yeah from Mohammed give it up
for Tori I look at my friend Tori it's
really some current events I bought I
brought doughnuts ruin do you don't say
hey Donna
I brought don't we got three Ross
whiskey damn
yeah I'll do Johnnie Walker Black
sometime this this hats Johnnie Walker
but that's adorable
it's gross well I'm paired to this
Johnnie Walker Black tastes like Johnny
what could piss your mouth compared to
this yeah they're super expensive
whiskey's that Brenda got that's a crazy
feeling froggy I [ __ ] Stevie blue
eyes and my buddy Herman I cracked that
bottle they were they were drinking it
like it was [ __ ] like they'd crossed
the desert like he was a man I hadn't
had any water for three days I'm like
hey [ __ ] die here like ice-cold Zima
well they cleaned me out
well they well they kill well they
finished the bottle that's why papa
can't give you this after I said to my
go guys this is $1,000 just be there
like yeah [ __ ] you have yeah I wanna
drink it I guess your boy might I just
signed a deal for that Yamato Japanese
with Yamato Yamato I don't know much
about that one oh you know about should
we do a taste test
go ahead oh yeah doctor come over for
life insurance so if I vow call my
breath thing I'm still good yeah you'll
be fine how many drinks you have a week
Bren I know he's gonna ask for that I
gotta figure it out you know I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say I only drink when
there's something to celebrate and you
say and there's a lot to celebrate these
days Oh Drake song is it
yeah not [ __ ] you can't drink right now
cuz you're gonna give blood that's true
you can't do it yeah it'll actually
where are you gesturing oh there's a
dream some time [ __ ] you yeah yeah I'm
aware of time without finance what guys
you didn't notice us sipping whiskey
let's retire he can't do that before
your check how about what you don't
think so no you were a little drunk the
last podcast we did I feel hey which one
with um who is our guest from last week
yeah Oh Mike Catherwood and yeah yeah I
think Brendan was a little drunk
probably it's called living dude I think
ever since you had the Japanese whiskey
delivered originally you've been Loki
drunk every single podcast every podcast
yeah don't buzz and I've gotten a lot
funnier I like I like whiskey whiskey
Brad what's the difference how do you
get I don't know get real racist oh yeah
you just look in the mirror like we're
doing here isn't this yeah yeah I'm
spoiled with my 23 that's nice though
this is nice
yeah gonna open at 23 Oh nope not for
you Bubba take it home probably okay
which one do I get seventeen year figure
it out we got chin oh it says 48 hours
before tests just for next time I guess
well I get the test the doom blood and
some other work I mean or 30 they told
me not to drink or anything three hours
before can you push it yeah let me
cancel right now i'ma say dude I've been
drinking the guy's been eating and
drinking we own it's doughnuts it's like
not a great you know and I'm go for life
and shift in case I die so my family
it's all my money
what should you not do before a physical
exam work out really hard look at you oh
hey no drink I shitload of coffee
even when you drink a lot of coffee
before your your it can spike your
cholesterol for whatever reason your
cholesterol can look hot abnormally high
your your little panel
okay what about BP what is blood
pressure blood pressure when you do
huffing I don't know I think yeah I know
I know smoking raises your blood
pressure like when you have a cigarette
your blood pressure will be higher I
guess yeah you mark and cut are marking
calendar business Gaza go there thing
goes hey man make sure you're ready for
4:30 today the doctors come to the house
is the second time we've scheduled oh no
it yeah no doubt hey yeah yeah no doubt
man
I appreciate the hard work you're gonna
hate me though I've been drinking with
is gonna have to cancel this and then
put the face going alcoholic no dude
this is crazy
why did usually go well that almost that
would this blood go so the other day
Jimmy Fallon went on Twitter and
apologized for a sketch that he did on
SNL about 20 years ago where he was
impersonating
Chris Rock I believe
and this is a clip of it
yeah you looked a little bit you're not
allowed clean yes please so even in
sketch you're not allowed to play your
cast mate
yeah bhai he's black he's doing a thing
of Chris Rock yeah so you're not allowed
to do even that's racist huh okay I
don't think black people feel that way I
bet most of them would be like what but
also there's got to be a statute of
limitations as well yes you know there
in when you apologize you give way to
these morons and actually make something
else and if we're if we're gonna cancel
culture anything which is so [ __ ]
stupid this is 20 years ago and he's
playing a character that has his friend
who happens to be black he's doing a
spot-on impression but there has to be
some responsibility if we're gonna get
mad at it which we shouldn't but we are
does satellite live not too anyways yes
ability who put the sketch together the
writers wrote it they filmed it and
okayed it but it just shows you the
temperature of America at the time like
this corporation wouldn't be
jeopardizing the dollars and putting
this on the air if that wasn't the
temperature but an agent at the time ABC
University NBC Universal it wasn't
nobody nobody when it was on and nobody
today if you really were honest yourself
would say this is this is Jimmy Fallon
being racist no no he was doing Chris
Rock in the sketches good friend it's a
comedy so he's playing Chris Rock so did
he what he asked you Rock though I'm
sure Chris was like right but then Chris
also has to be like well yeah I guess
the other thing is like if that wasn't
made today of course drag the person
like that's not a suit right well no
don't drive that's Romany it was calm
hat well I say just like there was a
time in place when it was culturally
acceptable maybe to do that for comedy
but by today's standards
definitely not but you have to take into
account this is 20 years we stopped out
what about what about Jimmy Kimmel
playing Carmel oh there's that yeah
there's countless cases of but that's
not that's not what I'm saying is that
it's all context to say that that's
offensive in 2020 is only you're saying
that only because there's a small
minority of people mostly white by the
way and super left who are saying that
this outrageous blackface yes there's a
history of blackface and it's a racist
thing I think nobody's saying that there
is ception to a rule where some
is doing something where you know
they're not race you know what this
isn't up but this isn't that this isn't
the problem the real problem would be
the young african-american who was
killed by the cop that's a problem right
Jamie that's right Valon doing this 20
years ago of a skid of his friend of
Chris Wragge I seen someone do that at
the wrong if someone did that today yes
I think people are there there yeah
they're projecting they are thinking
that this was made yesterday or
emotionally they believe that to be true
but you have to add context to it
understand this was done 20 years ago
and by today's standards yeah that's
kind of you wouldn't do that but society
has evolved and you have to factor that
in I can't believe the book this is a
conversation where people like Oh Jimmy
Fallon should lose his job over and you
guys would you guys cancel would you
guys take the Constitution in the Bill
of Rights and throw it away which is
given birth to the longest-standing
democracy the world's ever known and and
and has actually the language in that
those two documents are used to liberate
marginalized people and were used to
marginalize and abolish slavery etc the
founding fathers were slave owners a lot
of them does that mean that we take kid
yeah does that mean and they were I'm
sure racist and by but does that mean we
take what they created that incredible
document and it has no validity no you
have to separate the man from from his
work obviously there are inconsistencies
like you said historically there were
his store there with historical incident
this is he there are there are
inconsistencies in human as well the
thing is you can only be as woke as the
year you're in yeah so the standards you
have today you can't apply them to like
a hundred years ago well how are we
gonna go back yeah but if you can go 20
where's the limit we're gonna stop well
what about Picasso who treated women
like [ __ ] or Hemingway or than women
like that do you want to get rid of all
his art yeah do we want to get rid of
all Hemingway's writing well I'm curious
so I guess you have to be a saint you
have to be a perfect saint and a tutu to
do anything worthwhile because anything
you do I guess Woody Allen's movies I
don't think you know first of all but
let's just say whatever it is there are
people who create genius works of art
like dolly who are ghastly
who are who I wouldn't sleep are nasty
person or anything
Oh what about Michael Jackson so he's
never proved in the court of law that
he's a child molester a pedophile so
surely not plays music anymore because
those accusations well the greatest joke
like oh he told stillbirths greatest
joke as he goes if he did [ __ ] the kids
we're still gonna have to come to terms
with the fact that he wrote thriller and
that's [ __ ] genius how about him give
his joke away did he put that on special
all right or no probably I don't know a
little different yeah I think MJ stuff
is just so embedded in the culture of
the world that you can't remove it like
you can cancel Kevin Spacey you can try
to like remove r.kelly
but MJ it's impossible you know what I
mean why would you there's either he was
never proven a court of law
yeah if you if you go back and look at
all the all the articles that when you
actually look into it like what about
woody allen one way his stepdaughter
when she was seven had a memory seven
and and he in two court cases he was
exonerated but yet we're gonna cancel
him completely out there are a lot of
these things were hard wanna seem piece
of [ __ ] there's we know we know who the
pieces of [ __ ] are Bill Cosby you got
twenty sixty women come on come on we
know it we know the truth you know we
know what you did [ __ ] you got
to be in jail 100 percent 100 percent me
see this video sure rock now we're
talking
where is it man oh man who wants to be
me then guess what not a lot of black
folks on the show right
a lot of I remember when this air I love
Sno I grew up on it and it what there
wasn't a fervor at the time looking at
it now you're like you know yeesh
yeah after but that time you didn't
think of it yeah it was just like oh
that's a great Chris Rock yeah what
sounds a little what's happening is um
you know younger kids are discovering
these clips like it's new to them and
they don't realize that it was remember
they do but they're not thinking about
it that this is 20 years ago and the
world grows and evolves and think what
God were in a better place because you
have to it's like trying to find racists
it's like it's like a headhunting thing
it's like find the races and get in you
guys the border can do you becomes your
get you get you get social points for it
validation yes you get social points for
beginning they're so unhappy with their
lives
we get [ __ ] over Jimmy Fallon look at
this beautiful Ruben trying to talk at a
college and these people are getting on
with black lives matter black they won't
listen they're trying to drown them out
it's not helpful this is this is
actually not how you combat racism yeah
there is real racism it's nothing like
it's like choosing your battles yeah
there's like the way more than something
made 5 years ago yeah that's that's a
problem yeah you want it you want to
protest anything make a fuss about that
would be something to make it's amazing
is that this [ __ ] keeps on happening
like the video after video you think
like how long have cell phone cameras
been around and all that and like they
keep this stuff like this keeps on
happening what and it's scary but it you
know when Colin Kaepernick took a knee
this was exactly why took a knee when we
dissolve he's anti-americans anti no
till he's like no I'm not I'm bringing
awareness to how black people are
marginalized and how if they're
oppressed against police that's why I'm
taking it isn't it crazy how everyone
has a camera in their pocket and this
shit's still going on can you imagine
what life was like with no cell phones
in the day well that was the Rodney King
thing this is going black who said we've
been dealing with this forever
yeah like the Rodney King thing was that
was a momentous moment in American
history because a lot of black community
were like you think that's [ __ ] new
for us we've been dealing with that [ __ ]
forever
and they have so you know you can
understand the frustrations is this it
was in Minneapolis
yeah Minneapolis okay I can't even I
can't know why yeah it's like new ones
will come up and I just can't hit play
on these things
the stories can't watch that guy
kneeling on his neck like that for
multiple minutes like - some people say
eight sometimes two five either way
that's wrong now again that guy died in
my opinion that guy that that police
officer all do hard job they have but
that right there you're a [ __ ] idiot
you should go to jail
oh oh yeah all four should be on trial
for murder all four just sitting there
watching how does one oh my go dookey
office [ __ ] that here's I say but how
are you not here's what I'd say it's
possible it's possible that the [ __ ]
other is it pi is it possible is it
I miss question cuz I wasn't there I
didn't see the video that the other four
didn't understand the damage that was
being done to his neck I'll tell you
this right now let's say you look for
him that some weird beef let's say and
he came in to do the show and you guys
start fighting yeah and you you
eventually got Fahim down and you were
grabbing him putting your knee into his
neck yeah Oh Brian you're you're gonna
[ __ ] him up dude yeah what are you doing
yeah but now you we have carpet here now
imagine you're on blacktop yeah and the
cop is using the car as leverage and
driving the knee into the night yeah
[ __ ] you how just as a human being take
out being a cop dude dude you're gonna
kill what's the girl they're all bad
they're all pieces of [ __ ] yeah
how does not one of them go dude get the
[ __ ] off he's gonna die eight minutes
you know fast a guy can choke you out
yeah eight dude eight minutes and he was
begging for apparently yes
I think there's got to be serious for
percussions for this type of stuff why
does this have to go to prison do you
otherwise if they just lost their jobs
the governor came out does that well the
mayor goes well don't worry about the
elastic no you don't understand that's
not good enough
those guys have to pay those guys have
to pay and then you look at the city of
Minneapolis knowing that this isn't good
enough do you have the picture that chin
the streets are filled yeah why the
matter should be filled
it's not a race issue it's a human issue
yes like you do that to a human being
this kid happened 2020 man yeah and then
I think this this puts a little more
spotlight on Kaepernick where we gave it
done a [ __ ] oh you don't really want to
play football I even said that like do
how about if you can't breathe look and
that's not a black thing that's a human
thing
white black MEC
it's right Indian that's and that's that
that that's actually a good thing right
there when you see that you're like
there you go that's worth that's worth
protesting well this shows you the power
of the people the government don't have
the power the power that people do
because if no one did any of this those
guys don't lose their job you know that
would that guy that murdered in Georgia
they were gonna let those guys off yeah
yeah until finally it got blocked light
and then people get held accountable and
then they got to do something about it
they were just gonna fight they weren't
gonna fire those guys so there's this
huge protest
yeah it's not Schmitt trump protest
that's a different one frustrating me
yes I was a good friend of friend of
mine stacked
you know stacked from the up in all the
smoke Steven Jackson Steven Jackson one
of the nicest guys so they look like
brothers that's what I got in the
gentlemen on the left in the Hat is the
guy who passed away no skill they look
like these calm brothers they calm twins
they always are the twins and he asked
Steve Jackson she bought him clothes
he's on the left right there's one who
got killed they gue wrestle my hair I
see phenomena and be a player and it has
literally the biggest MBA sports podcast
of all time let's hit all the smoke
yes that's my ninth bucket super smash
turns stack I met it earlier yeah yeah
yeah he's there yeah they're great
oh yeah so last thing on this is Steven
Jackson actually bought him clothes like
a few days before or pretty recently
because this guy was trying to change
his life that's why he moved to
Minneapolis in the first place it's
terrible yeah what else you got here
well here's the lighter one there's
footage of two alligators fighting in
the middle of a golf course in South
Carolina I'm here for this yeah oh wow
wait
let's get a full screen on this let's
get on this do you think probably the
hardest fight is the American alligator
correct right
the one that cut has his eye
why are they doing this I feel like
there's a lot of Rhino because males
fight male male males during certain
seasons fight their ass on on on
crocodiles yeah crocodiles alligators
they fight them they fought yeah there's
so much room there yeah they're
territorial do you have the video my boy
Rex Chapman post this a 12 year old bull
at it what is it what do you see this
this night I was I was like this can't
be real
12 year old boy they're in rush or
something he's walking very slowly
because his dad tells not to run cuz
there's a hundred pound grizzly bear
stalk him and he's white he's wearing
that in 12 your Boyd's walking slow his
dad to go easy easy don't startle easy
the dads just filming it it's actually
in Italy is Italy in the 4th Russian
[ __ ] the boy actually watched videos
with it's a stepdad he watched videos
with the stepdad about how to react when
there's a bear well you watch this
beforehand so you knew how to be chill
let's go ahead and see this oh it's not
my biggest come on my biggest question
is III assume the best thing is if
you're the dad not to film it no the boy
asked him that's dad to film it to take
a picture but he's 12 you know I don't
he's like I may die but this is great
tick tock me - you got my Pokemon that's
it yeah that's Italy what do they do
whatever I make dog dance
the size is [ __ ] thing reverent - you
just slow the kids going yep he knew how
to act his [ __ ] is so tight high not
but he's so scared
well is that the bolt cut though check
the sprout
leave the barrel its problem game over
for that beer Suns go down now it's a
disaster
jeez look how big that thing is
problem is you know you as a father
gonna have to die you're gonna have to
run and his mom and his grandma are
screaming in the background and they're
telling the mom be quiet because it can
you find a chair that is it's a brown
bear it's like uh in Italy words yes
hold on let me see come on boy let me go
to this this has more information
stressful it makes me sweat so they'll
buy a counter Trento northern italy i
start with the brown yeah yeah it's a
bravura by Sorrentino I've been to
Trentino Trentino is a hold on it I
didn't lay a bird pears up there there
is mercy and love more seekin brown bear
I'd been sleeping yeah and then I'll
play this because they actually have
subtitles on this one and you can hear
the families here and I view the schema
don't give your back give me like MMA
advice Santino who's a fan of beers
everything up there I've been after
three times it's beautiful out there
damn [ __ ] in pine cones I never know
there were bears up there
[Music]
yeah me early anyway see that stuff
attending any he's just making sure he's
taking a picture when you like it then
they take on what a gangster family
though gangster the kid oh look at that
thing see the kids tell me to be quiet
who's whistling
and they're barely is right there ah can
you bring up them American brown bear I
wanna see how big they're nothing was
thick dude thick is [ __ ] dude you know
you don't want a bear hungry and eating
you how many people would freak out and
just just run I mean that's you don't
want to do that that's not your dad it's
like you want look stats here 6 foot 2 6
foot 6 yeah that's that's a large animal
that's how much it weighs although all
the let me read this I know which one
the murmurs from brown bear also knows
the Alpine brown bear is critically
endangered I mean this can you see how
much they weigh yeah pick its cuz I want
to know if they're [ __ ] like
Grizzlies you know what you know at
Grizzlies does it matter 170 pounds
bears you know it's a big bear 500-pound
bear would you see like a lightweight
bear and be like no I'm okay
he's only at 220 I do this is doable no
big that is do you know [ __ ] a
hundred pound dog like he's a police dog
little [ __ ] yeah I just can't believe
how gangster that kid was just walking
calm it was like because I told my son
Ron that's cool fish fighter Manish
you know promise yellow shoes can match
whatever Oh what else you got Jen let's
go to that crazy well we talked about
this when you were here with 10 Dylan so
there's this Japanese girl who was on a
show called terrace house I know if you
watch it on Netflix it's super popular
but Tara's Tara's house is a thing
evident development so I got scared for
a second
it's like a date he shows it so the
three people move in that are men and
three people are women and they see if
they can connect and have relationship
if they don't then they move out and
another person comes in it's pretty
entertaining like the real world he's
pretty she was very pretty like she
committed suicide because of online
bullying us cyber bullying and then so
Japan is actually probably gonna put
into litigation or we call like when you
make the law each you
is it litigation notes when you pass a
law ocelots litigation would be suing
somebody there's another word that
sounds for like that but yeah you're
almost gonna they're trying to pass law
now to prevent this from happening first
so if you you're held liable if you do
say something that someone kills
themselves yeah the problem with that is
that if that approved you have to be
very careful with that because now
you're dealing with freedom of speech
and you're saying if I say you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you kill you know three
days ago and you wrote a note that way
I'm liable for murder or lawsuit it's
very sticky its sticky but they have to
figure something out because there's and
there's a lot kids in America that are
committing suicide over sampling so you
can't just but I get free love speed
yeah that's me sometimes also before a
delicate like that and fragile that may
be part of the problem right but a lot
of times it's a huge problem always
committed suicide but suicides that
rates never been higher especially
amongst teenagers that's right
yeah it's so weird like I didn't grow up
with that you know to think that's such
a big part of kids lies nowadays I
everything so she was twenty-four hours
a day now like the bullying never stops
yeah I knew I was getting bullied in
school I not come back tomorrow I'll
deal with it but now they go home yeah
yeah nothing I was on Rogan talking
about this and and how he I have a
daughter in middle school so I'm pretty
you know sensitive to this but there are
anxiety levels and everything have
skyrocketed because of cyberbullying and
just and also suicide suicide for young
girls is actually so the difference
would be like it'd be like it used to be
one in a thousand now it's two in a
thousand so a lot but it's it's it's
it's still very vanishingly rare but I
just ran our clothes bring up suicide
rates amongst teenagers its highest-ever
do that might is that COBIT though is
that from relayer
no by the way the word was legislation
not litigation legend say youth suicide
rates are on the rise in the u.s. youth
suicide rates increased 56 percent this
decade ten to twenty four climbed 56
percent suggest that social media is on
among the teens the suicide rate among
educators people ages 10 to 24 years old
climb to 56 percent that's enormous
well it's it's not certain but it's gone
up every year right they can follow it
since social media became popular it's
gotta be yeah still if but
but yes they put that in the context so
of three girls per thousand kill
themselves if it becomes four that is a
you know that's a 25% increase or
whatever that's a 33% increase so that
that's what I'm time you wrote a whole
book about it that's fine but I'm
telling you straight up some statistics
suicide amongst teams due to social
media has never been higher that's true
that's probably that's that's what
Jonathan is yeah 56 percent which is
nuts
and now it's like it was even an option
when I was growing up yeah I had one kid
do it yeah there's like I don't know but
it was like now kids get like DS and
they're [ __ ] slitting their throats
it's nuts and then they tried blaming
that show on Netflix after 13 reasons
why yeah it's like this it's like this
proper thing to do because like would
lets out like you and who knows but with
this girl if she didn't become famous
would she have committed suicide you
know yeah and also maybe was just social
media you can talk to other people that
are depressed it becomes this whole no
you can't escape it yeah that's that's
right the issue is social media base
much for younger kids like bully a 24/7
yeah but then you might get bullied from
James in your earth science class but
now James is gone but then at Littleton
high school that you go to the kids that
chair creaking a pile on you because
they don't like what you did the kids
were at Overland High School in a pile
on and the kids in Eagle Crest
Compellent make sure you know you have
hundreds of dummies alone you up in this
kids either you have a different school
systems bullying you it's nuts
damn it's nuts yeah what do you do
I gotta be something man punishment
first of all your parents have to be
like don't [ __ ] pile on with this [ __ ]
but all its stars deal with look what
the Kardashians and these people deal
with where people get on and father just
ignore now they just your turn and the
one takin a yeah now YouTube videos have
this [ __ ] great family little kids
and some of the dad they saying Baba
O'Riley it's so [ __ ] good and I sang
like come together but he turns to
comments off you can't comment on it mmm
comments on YouTube are done he's like
no comments
so he just puts it up and you got likes
it was so great like 91 dislikes get the
[ __ ] out of here it was so good yeah
it's a tough border like is I'm with you
with freedom of speech and our amendment
and right so you have to have that but
at a certain point if it doesn't help
anything and it's just-
I don't know why we would support that
well when it comes to trolling like
there it shouldn't just be the Wild West
know the way you do it is I think that a
company that you use so YouTube what we
are to do this YouTube Instagram they
take a lot of heat for it but they will
censor you if you are they will take you
off youtube I mean they will take you
off if you are being this insulting
right no no they will people have been
taken off you yes and there's a service
where if you breach it yeah - much of
normal you don't get taken off YouTube
all time begging not as a commoner and
some but if they upload a video
trolling someone but not because comment
well no comments - like twitter twitter
when you say certain bad things i mean
what's his name is on it'll be a racist
stuff so i'm like that but if you're
just trolling then I can do sometimes
though it's not racist stuff sometimes
it's like just insulting [ __ ] which was
what Jack Dorsey took so much [ __ ] for
because he runs a huge company there are
people underneath him that were like
deeming some of them these things to be
well have you seen like well what
Instagram did so kids aren't so glued to
and put all their value on this game
it's you can't see likes anymore right
like you can't wait how many followers I
wasted there wasted there thought they
were talking about that right get away
for a while which I thought was
brilliant
I don't know if it has to be a law I'm
saying the company itself can create
their own rules social rules right which
they do have but they get [ __ ] for it
too so so in the so now you stop well
using youtuber instrument because I
can't hate on some well YouTube as an
automatic they just wrote an article
about this they have an automatic
deletion it's an algorithm to leads if
you insult the Chinese party with two
particular phrases 50-cent party and
another thing it automatically goes over
Chinese place a nice about the Chinese
Communist Party
so that's an algorithm that was deemed
by somebody at YouTube or some people as
deemed derogatory torch I knees 50 cent
party for whatever reason I camera I was
a you you joined the party for 50 cents
of something about that but so so
there's a there's Google was contacted
by the spectator or someone say ask him
for comments I haven't gotten back to
him yet but they noticed that there were
certain phrases that would caught him
out yeah promise it again now we're
dealing with sticky sheep because they
they're taking a lot of [ __ ] for it so
what but I do agree that my cousin you
know I really can't do any look I think
if a bunch of teenagers a bunch of like
well cuz we'd all of y'all's are ganging
up on one twelve-year-old we have to do
something about it and if it's cyber
it's bullying if you saw them doing it
in the school yard line you'd be like
hey but what's the wildest I don't do
anything yeah well it's hard to combat
it I guess I guess you could block
everybody yeah I mean you as a parent
you'd have to tell your kid like there's
a separation between like don't take it
seriously okay you can't them you know
what the problem is social media is so
new we don't know the only percussions
well we're seeing this suicide rate
super high we know some celebrity stuff
some super they suffer from depression
because of the comments they get yeah
this is like the new CTE we'll see what
happens we have friends who've who've
dealt with it and gone into deep
depressions just from the comments and
control you know you put something out
there you know it says just don't read
the comments yeah like I know what I do
man like really good at it but then
sometimes you need a slipper but it's
like do you want to dive into that pool
like you know what's there like very
rarely do you ever go into YouTube
comets and you're like I feel great I'm
glad I did know I want to do this sketch
for y'all had a great bit of YouTube
comments I want to do this once get to
where it's like I'm saying it's like
Lord of the Rings I'm saying goodbye to
my family at the village like I have to
go to the YouTube comments
shink shink I never I've never once read
of YouTube dumb no I've never have I
don't read them but the problem is I
have family members that'll read it oh
dude they're like these folks now so
it's my a I don't wanna hear yeah my mom
would call me she'd be like I saw you
uploaded that video do you read that one
guys like a 9-2 says yeah suck my dick
yeah yeah mom I read it I don't do mom
yeah when I was I was doing a shitty TV
show one time yeah but my my mother
would read all the comments she would
read this is before social media she
would read The Critic logs and she read
the critics and she'd be so mad that she
would write the critics back a letter
I'm like this is that oh don't worry
about it
the critic first of all it's kind of
right number one number two relax
they'll be putting the critical rights a
retraction like after being contacted
make some good point we're doing so much
work needed it takes so much work to do
this means they're so spiteful I'm like
well listen this is a business they're
kinda right yeah well maybe my dad you
get you gotta stay out of comments man
if you if you're not sound takes on the
road if you're not sold on the road no
one's watching podcast and you'll have a
fall on Instagram you're gonna hate on
for yeah and your fans will follow you
like the ones who don't like you who
gives a [ __ ] but like you keep putting
content out your fans will gravity oh
yeah weird the bigger you get the worse
it's gonna get yes that's kinda that's
gonna be 72 it's gonna be eight well
really ninety ten that's just felt good
about versed that bill Burgos I can't
believe say because you can say that you
can say everyone is [ __ ] that they
eight people on Twitter that eight
you're the one that's not really like
real like I've been getting a little
more and that's just I've realized I'm
kind of happy about it where like
obviously you don't want to get trolled
or hate on but it's just a testament
that you're getting bigger
yes just by sheer statistics not
everyone's gonna like you and that just
means you're reaching more people so if
you're getting more hate it just means
you're like your reach is getting fit
sometimes the comments are helpful like
I see I hate when people say though cuz
probably only for me when I did Rogen
one time I did an Indian I did an Indian
accent and it was live okay
Brown face and yeah let me know that
that's not to think we do anymore don't
do that no anymore my pockets
I don't do the brown face I don't tell
me duro but the guy said the guy goes
all the guy said was he goes hey Brian
just keep in mind that some Indian
people actually listen to Rogen and when
you do those comments it's kind of a
bummer I [ __ ] I I went that I get I'm
hurt this guy's feelings yeah I was like
I'll never do that again I'll never die
it just didn't on him you know sometimes
when it's couched like that - just like
this is how I felt my still loved you or
whatever yeah okay I was like well on
they come out like [ __ ] you yeah not
gonna take the note but if you're like
you know I'm Indian and that makes me
feel yeah oh maybe buddy Slade me he
goes just keep mind - yeah it goes keep
in mind Indian people like myself listen
to you and you know it's kind of Drock
Tory it's kind of a bummer cause like
I'm so sorry I swear to god I know I can
tell you all about Indian culture my
sister was born in Bombay picture of me
getting ticket and I run two paragraphs
and I was like huh this is a long time
ago and I've never forgot it it was the
book back when Rogan was I was doing
Rogen's podcast and his in his not his
garage but in his he had this shitty
room yeah like Road 1.0 yeah literally
read ban was the pretty not even I did
Brogan's podcast when I was just he and
I were two shitty mics like back in the
[ __ ] way way day
Oh crazy should you see that you know
what it was it was when I said to him
the Internet is only 5,000 days old and
he went his and I go isn't that crazy
that's how long ago I did I said the
Internet's only 5,000 days old and it
was thank you everybody
hey Brian but when you do stuff like
when you do the Asian accents and you're
just joking around it's actually funny
though so some people don't it's funny
with in depending on the cut and all you
did on the anybody I don't know if you
were doing like go Slurpees you know
what I was talking about how they D in
it like India it's got a billion people
and they don't win a lot of Olympic
medals maybe sets isn't about not being
as Athletica country I don't know
okay I said I can beat up the whole
country something like that whatever it
was was good work it wasn't cool and I
didn't of course I didn't mean anything
mean but I didn't even know what I was
doing until somebody said well my
brother said we'll get emails and be
like I feel bad for chanting cat when
Brenda and Bryan do Asian accents or
whatever yeah
that's trust me if I thought it was bad
to do him from we wouldn't be doing it
well they weren't okay with her we heard
it also helps a cat and Jen are American
I'm not which it was yeah yeah I'm
Americanized we're gonna say for him oh
yeah I found that like the better you
are at a foreign accent even if you're
not that race if you nail it all is
forgiven
it's pitch perfect yeah if you're a
white and you do an Asian accent people
don't give a [ __ ] well like the further
you have you're right if it's an
approximation people are like racist
well if you're right on when Jillian
Johnson Creek told Joe yeah this is so
good she's so spot-on through I did my
African accent about the Rhino thing I
don't have you seen it this comic who's
up he's African he's from [ __ ] he's from
Maui City he was over there he was from
Ghana or something and he came out to me
he goes dude I was ready to go bad on
you the minute I saw you talking about
Africa and when I heard your accent and
the words you were using in the
placement he goes mad respect yes like I
was scared you double down lingo
blackface I sure did I do it in
blackface and that's but that's you know
yeah it was but it you're right you're
walking right because you took the time
to really study the cadences yes and I'm
also talking about how this guy
embarrassed me because he was smarter
than that one it shows it's kind of a
love letter then rather than like a
loose approximation that's how someone
certain people speaks it's nothing wrong
with doing that yeah like Santino's have
you heard Santino's Indian accent no
it's pretty good yeah I mean I'm not I
don't know but it sounds pretty heavy
had this bit at the Laugh Factory where
he would say he was adopted by an Indian
family and that's why he talks that way
so he went onstage that way and he did
like six minutes just talking about like
how he's like a ginger
okay you should be censored what else
you got this here doug liman who
directed I think edge of tomorrow with
Tom Cruise admit you know so apparently
Tom Cruise and him and Elon Musk are
partnering up to film something in outer
space a movie in outer space news Tom
Cruise something in outer space like
he's just floating in the soil you see
the suit I've seen the new astronaut
suits nowhere near as cool back then
back in the day where dragon day they
were like marshmallow men have the cool
mask what are the new SpaceX ones is
just I think the Sun I think Kanye might
have designed them I don't know but they
look [ __ ] shitty visually Oh like that
yes we all go into the clothes you look
like a Halloween costume
yeah that's not just not yes they seem
too accessible or two attainable I think
they already universe and get this you
have to be an astronaut they're like you
have to like it's really hard to be an
answer I'm sure those suits are way more
functional than the ones we're used to
they're custom made this is like a
Coachella or some Mars you had the
chance
no I would like a one-way ticket
tomorrow no [ __ ] no aren't they they're
selling tickets though right to get to
Mars you know to have a gun with me so I
could stick it in my mouth whoa oh that
just that hope they're trying to shoot a
film in they're actually planning on
filming in outer space I think they even
mentioned the space station or something
come to raise like that idea because yes
you have to mimic like how good gravity
did it with [ __ ] George Clooney in
yeah girl I know what she's oh real yeah
and you're gonna try I'm not gonna go oh
my god I shot that in outer space so
gravity looks so legit you know Tom
Cruise is pretty like hardcore but
they've all as does
yeah all that stuff so it seems like
something he would actually do but then
you just relax I'm saying they used to
shoot like stunts aren't as dangerous on
set anymore like being an extra is the
most dangerous so he's gonna do all his
own extra work he's crazy all right
doug liman boy look Jake crazy the guy
looks so crazy on the left yeah I guess
the last one is just we talked about my
testing before um but so a bare-knuckle
fighting championships the often I'm
twenty million dollars before it should
come back and fight in their
organization but now they're upping it
they're saying that pay more than twenty
million dollars and they're even
thinking of having them fight Wanderlei
Silva v gotta watch that was really
gonna offer what it's gonna take to get
him back cuz he's in shaped pretty sure
they're Iver in shape right now
who'd he fight like some like X UFC
fighter who's not he's not going to
speak anymore but they're both out there
prize this sort of like the big three of
fighting yes yes the big three here
knuckle with tight Mike Tyson I don't
care who you I bet on mines oh yeah I've
micro knock him out at heart is that
right yeah have you seen Mike lately
shred so [ __ ] it and so much faster than
you but you but you get a you get a
figure
Wanderlei Silva is also gonna be on
whatever Mike Tyson's on yes for sure
Maryland Bentley sylia that face surgery
he's a yeah this is his fighter classic
hall-of-famer personally invited to come
to ax murder he's too used to do this
all the time for a fight look crazy had
all these wars and it's face because the
scar tissue just started get like a
shar-pei and then he moved to Vegas and
was like I'm just gonna get like the
scar tissue removed ain't got a full
[ __ ] the full get up everyone's like
well who the [ __ ] is that man look at
Mike's body yeah yeah 52 she'll very
late silver before after pictures
Brian this could be you when he getting
your live bang June 16 yeah Vanna died
so you're gonna do it you're already
beautiful Ryan no I love you Kat
my girl I love my girl thanks that's
kind of one with he looks more like this
now yeah yeah and on the right was him
before so this is how he is now but then
the left is what he look like before not
bad what's wrong with the left the nose
change his eyes changed a little bit too
young well I Got News for you guys he
had his eyes done yeah yeah definitely
but he said he told everyone he was gone
they're like now he was he had some work
done there
yep so what's the lids thing how does
that work
do you know how Brian's eyes have like
how they have like they just look like I
is committed well you know how they have
like the visor the skin box is open
I didn't see it until the dramatic turn
no no I get it look I got a lot of I got
a lot of meat over my eyes so what they
do is they just take the skin and I just
told you this told me to do it my mother
did it she goes people in our family
because you're legalized on taste get it
done before like so nobody notices get
it done when you're young so you don't
get it when you're 70 well by the time
your skin keeps going yes I know cuz
then I'm like this and I can't see it so
the insurance covers it because when
people like me you actually you're your
vision gets compromised so before that
happens on a validate you again that's a
back surgery that's the fact that's why
insurance covers it hmm because
otherwise you're now I'm going to Jason
diamond that's Kourtney Kardashian's
doctor my yeah so I'll bring up Courtney
before-and-after for a second plus the
guy Gordon something diamond now hold on
hold on Jason diamond now hold on
that's elective surgery no it's the
other one it's no show show who's the
other star - Chloe that's that's the
clone watch this well you don't I mean
she just came out recently with this
picture oh yeah that was like making the
rounds on Twitter yeah yeah it's like
it's just like an entirely different
person come on Khloe Kardashian cues
have changed her face was surgery wealth
anyways accusing her I think we're all
like yep that's what she did yeah and
that I Got News for you that was that
was certainly go to that that went after
when she was like super thick this one
like Rob with a wig on no Mary versus
before and after Jim yeah no one's
thinking about Rob how the [ __ ] do they
do that how the today's you know John
alright she's a cow on the left now
don't say that she's a big girl
don't she doesn't eat grass and she's
she's she's she's fiercely handsome in
that left side and she's just like you'd
want her to grow a line this jameth Rose
I want it by
strong girl and then over here she did
something I don't know man that is I
don't know but I sell it very what's
wrong like if you have your money of it
like she's yeah drop-dead gorgeous on
the right dose interesting so once you
get big enough you can make a drastic
change to your face like that and just
pretend like nothing happened
no you know you going to interviews and
it's like the elephant in the room and
like no one addresses how to address it
like this is always been my favorite awk
to me about my movie like everyone knows
the guy's the big is it's the amount of
filler and the amount of like face
tightening and like what does a face
feel like and that's Kylie's the
craziest that's nuts I know I would say
like Chloe's on par with that that's
like a lot of renovation I don't know
yeah that's nuts dude
well she had her lips definitely the
lips done thank doctor 100% she's got a
great face for it she had a good face to
be get really good job to begin with
them they when you're a surgeon you go
alright we've had a good starting point
I like the palate we're gonna genius not
that on the chisel this off will narrow
this down the nose is genius though they
product just a little bit Wow she's
swallow hot now tits her ass a lot of
work dude oh my god
that's excessive that was you what she
looked like you can't blame girls with
all the pressure they go under and all
the fun people and how were the haters
and then I [ __ ] this I'm just gonna try
to look beautiful wait it's over there
what is kylie jenner plastic surgery
over there no doubt yeah well she's not
a white chick pair white it's got to be
tough though here like a girl growing up
in the burbs or whatever and this is
normalized and it's just like this has
become communities at this please I'm in
this town but like over there it should
be a different standard you know what I
mean like if you're in Iowa you're like
yeah that doctor is a genius
seriously that's that's [ __ ] him
she's also a billionaire you know that
she's got a billion dollars cuz she
sells her makeup
what are you doing a brine huh what are
you doing it when I find a doctor they
can make me look back at that good
doctor die now your diamond I think June
16th
that's so yeah I gotta go do
and what if you coming out here he comes
in and no one notices by the way hey
guys Buffy's like hugs your day going
what if he just looks surprised hey I
gotta go have a guy like chase I gotta
have a constellation cuz I gotta make
sure he knows this is what I watch every
podcast guess when he's looking at her
oh just what I want to look surprised
all the [ __ ] time
I can't wait together cuz I've been
doing this now I feel good papa what
about what about the wrinkles I'm not
touching my [ __ ] wrinkles now I could
go like this here's where you get in
trouble as a guy watch the whole the
back
they pull it back now look where my
eyebrows are food you are legal smooth
them yeah I know I look like a [ __ ]
old guy who got plastic surgery can't
have that can't see that I have flange a
good eight hours sleep a little Botox
and the wrinkles they do with guys my
age I'm not doing Botox I will never do
Botox I will never do anything but my
[ __ ] lids your expression says your
moneymaker I remember it so Gordon
Ramsay did Botox and he looked very very
like smooth afterwards that's probably
not the one
hey Gordon you're a stud you're you're a
[ __ ] giant man be a man
what the the the earthworm jim [ __ ]
scales on his forehead are distracting
dude [ __ ] boys got some diva lines yeah
he's a pro soccer player he's a [ __ ]
giant oh did any hurt himself and that's
how I got names your size be big guy
yeah he's part of the big boys bike club
oh yeah he's only he's a good guy he
brings the snacks ah
yeah it is he had his Liz he had
something done with his [ __ ] eyes I
can see more eyeball hmm he had all the
work done look at his [ __ ] chin dude
that's a strong chin Bubba yeah now is
that that's from Botox or filler I
remember him saying something about
Botox and he looked very different
smooth after boathook him down there is
that even really him that looks like a
boxer he looks like a [ __ ] alien look
at that yeah Wow so maybe he had real
plastic surgery too
listen dude if I can if I can just look
a little less we just don't know what it
would look like we don't know what
Kylie's healing looks like when she's 60
now like social media we don't know I
always thought that it's not great we
know it Lance
all right we'll keep going but
with plastic surgery it looks great
until it doesn't it's like it's a
gambling you're like yeah keep on
winning and you know you don't know when
to stop lose it's bad yeah you do the
last procedure and you're like I tempted
failure be careful that's why that this
whatever that kardashian girl looks
night and day
yeah but wendy is if it's when work your
whole levee break so every three MS yeah
every three to six months they get
filler they do all this filler so v6
yeah so what they do with the jaw is
they'll del they shoot filler in your
jaw to make it more pronounced okay I
don't know what they do with like the
bones maybe they have a way to shave the
bones that I don't [ __ ] know I would
imagine they do but that when you
represen they gave her curves yeah chin
didn't you get Botox yeah for the the
mandible area massacres why did Saad
bruxism you know when you wouldn't get
you grind your teeth too much it's in
the sleep or what yeah
and that my teeth are actually cracked
on block like top and bottom so did that
and then it's splendored my even though
my face doesn't look that slender it's
lighted up a ton this side in this side
these are huge muscles right here yeah
how much I want to do something well
couldn't you just do have a mouth garden
or like a night guard I could have but
it's such a simple last way to do it you
know the question is one is Brian gonna
go on testosterone uh-huh
the other question is when is Brian
going to [ __ ] is he gonna get his
lids done they're a lot of questions no
you're getting Earl it's done
yeah a few I think you while you're
there previewing it
yeah just test driving it I can see Oh
daddy's eyes are getting bad I think
they look good told you hey Brad are you
a victim of cyberbullying ready yeah I
get a lot of women are like don't get
your lids done then I guess I'd be like
hey rinks get those [ __ ] eyes quietly
in the comments so you agree no just my
dams my dams that's a passionate troll
when they open the dm's like all this
guy cares i following
if it's a confident DM is like Kenny for
now yeah I got me neither you need to
see this we love your legs if you wanted
to pull you aside and like you know go
first he goes hey big fan then once you
accept and they go [ __ ] you you've
changed my life
psyche you [ __ ] suck doctor you need
to quit gotcha
screenshot yeah is that it that's it my
special look at the jaw now now that I
am no I I can't look at a face in LA
without an eye we can do you think dr.
Don could just take the puffiness out of
my fat face I don't think it happens but
you gotta make it suck it no you got to
take skin from Kylie Jenner's [ __ ]
transformation you can't hook your boy
up be a man you're you're manly just be
manly yeah now you be manly the only
thing I would do I've told you my nose
the only thing I've a good nose what do
you mean no watch but watch it could I
have why do you tuck the ears we can do
this you know touch my sack do this or
we can do what I personally like my
grandma so maybe pull it back pull it
back should show dr. diamond if you like
just take a little on my face oh that's
good no that's nice Brendan Kardashian
over here I think I look like the guy
from don't [ __ ] with cats Oh
Luka Magnotta huge I watched that whole
documentary and then I will get my ref I
was at the Comedy Store and I was like
I'm gonna do an impression some of you
might know this some of you might not
I don't know what it is but uh I go oh
yeah I'm Luka Magnotta
five-foot-ten I could take my shirt off
you guys name you take three people were
like loving video maybe like Halloween
I'm looking mcnaught uh um it was just
such a weird I didn't watch it he was a
sex worker he went to jail
well I do have a cigarette oh sorry
[ __ ] need a cigarette he was he was
mailing body parts to different places
nope nope nope nope
yeah I think he was no I know that only
one conscious yeah but he mailed his
body parts to like have an elementary
school another [ __ ] and wasn't it crazy
wasn't he trying to recreate Basic
Instinct or something yeah because he
killed the guy with the pic yeah well
that and then also when he was getting
interrogated he was like can I get a
cigarette and there's like movie and
then they put it all together like usual
suspects [ __ ] just crazy
he was compat documents you know people
are go crazy over [ __ ] Tiger King
yeah a couple Tigers night this is right
you gotta see this whoever bought this
book group tracked down a serial killer
a Facebook group he was a psycho
[ __ ] look at him you know and
you know I got spoiler alert in 3 2 1
suck it he got caught because he was I
think it was in Germany and he went into
like internet cafe and he was looking up
himself and the guy the owner of store
went by I was like oh [ __ ] that's the
guy called in these [ __ ] German
soldiers game yeah and got him like 10
people walking back to [ __ ] America
yeah those Germans don't [ __ ] around a
storm and they had surveillance footage
of the store the internet cafe and you
see like 10 German soldiers just like
walk in and then they're like this and
then they take it see if you can pick up
an image of that that's badass
yeah there's special forces that dude
there with a bunch of dudes built like
you come in in you yeah man how crazy
that long yeah like they were taken off
planes all all this is for me
exactly this is the closest I got
yeah well you should put a bullet in his
head cuz he's sick it would be best to
shoot him I like when they interview his
mom she's like listen I don't think he
did it
yeah yes he's not the biggest animal
lover that's a testament to moms they'll
love mom matter what
yeah I'm just love you no matter what
swamps teeth were more distracting than
anything
I'm gonna watch I'm gonna finish it all
right kids oh yeah yeah so okay a while
ago my first special that came out was
on seeso and nobody knows what the [ __ ]
that is it just called there's no
business like show business what was it
on it was on seeso which was like NBC's
defunct streaming thing but Comedy
Central just released it on their
YouTube for free so yeah it's on their
channel if you go to a comedy central
stand up and the entire hour is on there
but then you also released another one
right no just just this one which is the
one you shot in the belly room now
that's just me recording and not
chopping it up yeah yeah but this is
like a night like Aristotle the guy who
yeah who saw the videos before he
directed it and it's cool cuz I'm
getting DMS and [ __ ] people are finally
seeing it when it was in comedy jail
before yeah you know cuz like sometimes
you'll make these things and company's
gonna be like the paradigm has shifted
no one watches it unless it's streaming
like Netflix or streaming it's true or
YouTube who's gonna watch it so I think
it's so cool it's finally on YouTube oh
yeah that's great man good for you buddy
Thanks people can definitely see it on
there you know yeah like he doesn't have
you do i watch everything on youtube i
watch you guys on there and how long how
long did you shoot this like two years
ago yeah yeah no that's Lance is special
you gotta you gotta wait for that one
that's cool man yeah it's strange it's
cool that's like show business the full
specials right on YouTube right now yeah
how many it's not show YouTube cut out
of it you know it's basic I figured
black I'm not gonna sweat through it or
it's not gonna show
smart the pants I'm still wearing
wearing special pants dude cool look at
that white why the white shoes them I
just like the way it popped on the
background like a yeah it's clean white
shoes like you know just look big those
are just vans just simple there's big
though you know well what would you do
like dunks or something or Jordans
yeah for sure
but I feel like everyone's doing that
like the Lea does it like jokowi does it
every comic has like Nikes on that's
fair
no one has blank vans no one has nursing
shoes when they do they're special and
my special honestly it's best consumed
without sound
I'm very physical and my voice is kind
of shrill so it's best to be hit the
mute try and enjoy babies love it
dogs yeah I'm not in the talkies now
this ruins that don't love it man thinks
coming in brothers are having me rocket
ship that's hey guys you said John I
we're off to Houston all think all all
tickets are sold out in houston blah
blah okay I think I'll think it's a she
we got Phoenix oh and Jim Dylan's
jumping on Phoenix with us oh yeah Brian
Tim Dylan myself Phoenix June 11th
through the 13th those tickets almost
sold out as well and I'm in Spokane
Washington that's June 25th to 27th 27th
is the thick boy bike club ride well I
think we're gonna have to cap it but
there's still some spots available to
sign up at sick boy ride at gmail.com
and then also Salt Lake City wise guys
July 16th through the 18th the bike ride
will be on the 18th in Salt Lake City
sign up at Fick boy ride at gmail.com as
well that's it man tik-tok connor it is
big boy calm for any sick boy gear Fahim
we love you thanks man watches special
it's on Comedy Central YouTube that's it
let's see in Houston y'all
here's hot butter kid we're out